Yeah.
>> Awesome. What do you think about my
topic, man? Why does Allah copy Jesus,
bro?
>> Uh, I don't think Allah copies Jesus.
>> You sure?
>> Yeah. The historical Jesus or the real
Jesus who walked and breathed.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You said
the the real historical Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> Who that?
>> I don't know.
>> So then how you know that Allah didn't
copy him?
>> My only source for him is in the Quran.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, uh where where was Jesus
born?
>> Um doesn't mention so in the Quran.
>> Oh,
>> okay. Where was he from?
>> Um
so it says in the Quran that he came to
Benny is so I assume somewhere near
Jerusalem, you know, Palestine area.
>> Nope. Israel was the Israelites were
scattered all over the place.
>> Yeah. So, so, so what's the argument for
why Jesus?
>> Well, wait. First, we have to get who
the who the real Jesus is before we that
that's that this is secondary. The first
thing is who Jesus is. And then we could
talk about if Allah copied him or not,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you don't know where Jesus was
born. You don't know where he was from.
Um, all right. What how about how he
practiced religion? Did he fast?
in the Quran.
Actually, I don't even think it
mentioned that in the Quran either.
>> You're right. It's crazy. What about
What about his prayer life? How many
times a day did he pray?
>> I mean, in the hadith,
yeah, it doesn't mention that.
>> Nope. What about how he prayed?
>> No. Yeah. I don't think we need to know
that, though. Uh, all we need to really
know is that he worshiped one God.
>> Now, it's irrelevant. Huh?
I mean, I never I I mean, we follow
Muhammad. That's that's that's the
prophet for all of mankind, like for us.
>> Okay. And you know what Muhammad tells
you to do when you are in doubt about
these type of questions?
>> What do you mean? Oh, yeah. Tells It
says go ask the
come to us.
>> So, it doesn't look like you're
following Muhammad that well, man.
>> Where where did where can you uh
actually quote the exact verse where it
says that? Chapter 10 verse 94.
Chapter 10 verse 94. It says, "If you
are in doubt about that which we have
revealed to you, then go and ask those
who have been reading the scripture
before you."
>> So, uh you know the context of that
verse.
>> Yeah.
Talk it mentions uh stories of Moses. It
mentions Noah. Talks about uh um
Muhammad's prophethhood being mentioned
in our books.
Pharaoh, the Exodus, all kinds of stuff.
>> Yeah. So, to be fair, that doesn't
actually mention anything about Jesus.
>> So, it says if you are in doubt about
what the Quran says, then go and ask
those who been reading the scripture
before you. Doesn't have to be doesn't
have to specifically say anything about
Jesus prior to.
>> Okay. So, can we get to the argument?
>> Well, we don't know who Jesus is, who
the real Jesus is yet.
The real Jesus, the real Jesus according
to the Quran was a man who
uh worshiped God, was born to Mary, uh
virgin birth, and he's going to be back
to, you know, helping the day of
judgment.
>> Where does the Quran say that he'll be
back on the day of judgment?
>> I think that's in hadith actually.
>> Okay. So, so far what we've learned is
that your Quran
>> doesn't even really know who the real
Jesus is.
>> I mean, to be fair, there's about
124,000 prophets, you know, throughout
all of mankind that we actually most of
them not mentioned at all in the Quran.
>> So, I don't think that's the job of the
Quran for us. The job of the Quran for
us is to issue guidance for us from us.
then you shouldn't have said that the
true historical Jesus and his
information you get from the Quran. You
shouldn't have said that if that's not
the Quran's job.
>> Yeah, but I mean to be fair that's not
exactly what I said. I said the only
information I have of Jesus is in the
Quran. I didn't say that the Quran's job
is to give us that information.
>> You did say that Jesus that Allah did
not copy the real historical Jesus which
you get from the Quran.
No, you're right. I did say that. My
bad.
>> So, since we do not get the historical
Jesus from the Quran, where do we get it
from? If we want to know who Jesus was
historically, right? Since the it's not
the Quran's job to do that. Fair enough.
Where do we go? If I want to know who he
was historically, where he was from,
where did he preach uh preach, who were
his disciples and um what was the
conflicts that he was having with the
the his community? You know, like this
information, how did he practice his
religion? How did he fast if he fasted?
How did he pray? How did he teach to
pray? You know, if I wanted to learn the
historical Jesus, where would I go?
>> If you were to ask a scholar, they'
probably tell you
this. This isn't information for us to
>> not not a scholar would tell you to go
to the angil like the Quran tells you to
>> right
>> go to the gospel
come to us.
So cool.
>> Okay. So, the historical Jesus is is
found in the gospel and I'm about to
show you some things that uh Allah stole
from him or copied from him. Okay.
>> Right.
>> All right. So,
if we go to chapter 22
verse 7,
chapter 22:7 of the Quran, I'm gonna put
on the screen. Hopefully, you'll be able
to see it. I know the quality is
probably not the best on Tik Tok right
now, but we'll try our best. We'll go to
chapter 22:7.
And this is what it says.
It says, "And surely the hour is coming.
There is no doubt about it. And
certainly Allah will resurrect those who
are in the graves."
>> Right? So the one who's going to come at
the last hour, all right, who's going to
come at the hour and resurrect
those who are in the graves is Allah.
That's God, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I want you to wa watch this, bro.
Watch what Jesus says
here.
It's really amazing.
Let's see here.
Watch this. This is John 5:2. You can
see the screen. I know it's probably
blurry, but you can see it.
>> Yeah, I can make it out.
>> Okay. It says, "Truly, truly, I say to
you, an hour is coming, and now is when
the dead will hear the voice of the Son
of God, and those who hear will live."
He
>> gets even he gets even clearer. Watch
this. He says just a few verses later,
"Do not marvel at this, for an hour is
coming in which the all who are in the
tombs will hear his voice and will come
forth. Those who did the do uh good
deeds to a resurrection of life, those
who committed the evil deeds to a
resurrection of judgment."
So Jesus says that
the hour is coming. It's it's really
crazy how it look at the I put them side
by side. Look at the Quran says, "And
surely the hour is coming." There's no
doubt about it. Jesus says, "Do not
marvel at this, for an hour is coming."
And what does it say? And certainly
Allah will resurrect those who are in
the graves. And Jesus says, "Which all
who are in the tombs will hear his
voice, the son of the son of God's
voice, and will come forth." Right? So,
I mean, word for word,
bar for bar,
he stole his whole food.
Yeah. So, so when you make So, when you
So, when you show us things like this
and like make these claims, is it like
you're claiming that the Quran is
plagiarizing the Gospels? Is is that is
that is that is that the claim here?
>> Well, in a way, yes. In a way, yes. Um,
but there's
um there's a more important point that
I'm trying to make.
>> I don't know. Wait, wait, wait.
>> Not not simply that the Quran is
plagiarizing the Bible. I mean, we can
argue that. I I don't I don't
necessarily care about that. Honestly,
what I care about is that you see the
connection that by the Quran's
standards, Jesus is God according to the
Bible. According to the gospel, the
things that Jesus says about himself
by the Quran standards, he's claiming to
be God. Can we agree with that?
So what Jesus says in the gospel,
>> if he was to say that in the Quran, then
Jesus would be claiming to be God in the
Quran
>> or both. Really, it doesn't matter if he
says in the Quran or just in the Bible.
Like this this statement that I'm
showing you that I showed you where
Jesus says that at the hour he's going
to be the one who raises the dead and
he's sending people to either eternal
life or eternal judgment. And Allah says
the same thing about himself. Allah says
the hour at the hour he's going to be
the one who resurrects the people from
their graves.
So this is something only God does
according to the Quran. Right.
>> Yeah. I mean if we were to if we as you
know Muslims and as human beings were to
take the Gospels as authorative
witnesses over the Quran then yes we can
make this argument. But obviously in the
Quran it tells us to take the Quran as
an authorative witness over the gospel.
>> No it doesn't.
>> No it doesn't. But let me give you that
for for now. It doesn't I totally
disagree. We could talk about that
later. I love that topic. But what I'm
saying is is that you don't have to
believe the Bible. You don't have to
believe the Bible. Like for examp I
don't believe the Quran. I don't I I do
not believe the Quran is from God.
However, I can be honest with what the
Quran is saying. Like even though I
don't believe it, I can still
acknowledge, okay, yeah, it's saying
that Allah is God who raises the dead at
the hour. I I I that's what it says. I
can't say it doesn't say that. I can't
say that that's not the case. I would be
being dishonest. So, I'm just asking you
guys to do the same thing that when I'm
showing you this stuff in the Bible,
even though you disagree with it, you
don't believe that this is the word of
God, you don't believe that this is from
Allah, but at least acknowledge that
based on the Bible, based on the text in
the Bible, Jesus is claiming to be God.
>> Yeah. Based on the Bible, I mean, you
could I could grant that. I'm not an
expert on the Bible, but I I have one
issue with what you're saying. Can I can
I tell you what my problem is?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. So, if the Quran is plagiarizing
the Bible,
>> your your claim is that the Quran is,
you know, confirming the previous
scriptures, you know, blindly and
stupidly because apparently to you the
previous scriptures contradict the
Quran. But if the Quran is confirming
the previous scriptures blindly, how
could it plagiarize a book? Because it
clearly if the author of the Quran is
plagiarizing what you say about Jesus in
the Gospels, the author of the Quran is
clearly aware of what is said about
Jesus in the Gospels.
>> No, he's aware about what people say,
not about what say.
>> Exly. For him to plagiarize it and then
attribute himself to those things, like
you said, word for word, bar for bar,
you know, like for him to copy it, he
has to be aware of what's in it. So if
he's copying it,
>> he's just aware of what people say. He
doesn't know that the scriptures
actually say this, which is why he puts
his own twist on it and applies it to
Allah, not Jesus or himself in other
places,
>> right? So, how could he copy something,
right, attribute it to Jesus without
knowing that it was attributed to Jesus?
>> For example, for example, let's say I
never read the Quran a day in my life
and the only time I'm ever hearing about
the Quran is from you. Is from what
you're telling me what is supposedly in
there right
>> now? I don't know. I I didn't never read
the Quran, so I don't know if what
you're saying is true or not, but I'm
taking your word for it. And so, I'm
taking what you say. Let's say you you
say like in the Quran, it says, you
know, uh at the hour Allah is going to
raise people from their graves. That's
what the Quran teaches. And I'm like,
okay, well, I don't believe that. I
believe that it's going to be uh myself.
I'm going to be the one who raises the
dead at the hour. And then I write that
down. Does that mean And now when I
write it down, let's say I wrote it down
right here in my Oh, where's my
notebook?
>> Where's my revelation?
>> But then would that not be stupid of you
now to confirm the book that said it was
Allah doing it and not me? You
understand what I'm trying to say?
>> It's I don't know. I I don't I don't I
don't know. I don't know if you're lying
or not or you know I I I don't know the
book. So, it's But I would agree with
you. I would agree with you that it
would be stupid of me to confirm a book
that I'm not aware of. I I think that
Muhammad made a great mistake here that
exposed him as a false prophet cuz he's
confirming books without knowing what's
in them.
>> But here's the problem. You just said
he's plagiarizing it. So, he he has to
be aware somewhat of what's in it.
>> Did you
Okay, let me do this for you. I'm going
to ask you to do the same for me. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> I'm going to steal man your point.
Meaning, I'm going to represent what you
just said and what your what your
argument is. I'm going to repeat it back
to you, right? In a way that you're
going to be like, "Yeah, that is what
I'm saying." Then I'm going to ask you
to do the same for me. And what my point
is, okay, your point is is that, okay,
granted all of this, I'm saying that
Muhammad is plagiarizing
the Bible. In order to plagiarize the
Bible, he would have to be aware of what
the Bible says. But my other arguments
is that Muhammad doesn't know what the
Bible says. So then how can I sit here
and say he's plagiarizing? I'm basically
contradicting my other arguments. That's
what you're saying, right?
>> Yeah. By saying he's confirming it and
>> Yeah. By saying he's confirming it
blindly.
>> Yeah. Blindly. Yeah. Exactly.
>> So I I understand what you're saying. I
understand your point. What's my point?
>> Your point is Sorry, hold on.
So, so the point you're trying to make
here is
the point you're trying to make here is
that Allah or Muhammad is copying what
he heard Christians say is in the Bible,
right?
>> And he's attributing Allah to where
Jesus is supposed to be in the Bible.
That's that's your point basically.
>> Well, from what they say.
>> Yeah. So they say this it says in the
Bible this about Jesus and then Muhammad
says okay that's what it says about
Jesus in the Bible. Okay let me say it
says that about Allah in the Quran and
then say let me confirm the Bible. You
see how that like it kind of doesn't
make sense.
>> I agree with you. It's it's that's why
it's a dilemma.
>> No from your argument from your argument
it doesn't make sense.
>> No no no. You're you're you're thinking
that Muhammad has to be right and know
things. So you're you're you're assuming
that Muhammad is a competent guy. So
therefore, my argument against him just
doesn't make sense. No, it makes perfect
sense. Muhammad is hearing things from
people about Jesus. He's hearing
traditions. He's hearing stories. He's
hearing all these things about Jesus. He
doesn't know if these things are He
doesn't know if these things are in the
scriptures or not. He doesn't know. He
hasn't read them himself. He has to
trust and rely on them. Which is why he
says when they they were reciting the
Torah in Arabic, he told the Muslims,
don't believe what they say, nor
disbelieve what they say, right? But say
we believe in what was revealed to us
and what was revealed to you. So believe
in the scriptures, but take what they
say with a grain of salt cuz what they
say could be the truth or what they say
could be a lie. You don't know because
you don't know their books. So in light
of that, Muhammad is hearing traditions,
hearing stories, things that he it seems
like he agree with, he's cool with it.
Things that it seems like, oh, these
traditions, oh wait, no, that that that
that ain't right. He'll apply those.
He'll take those things and put an
Islamic twist on them and say, this is
this actually is for Allah, not a
prophet,
not knowing that this actually is in the
gospel when he affirms it.
>> Yeah. But that that presupposes that
when he heard those traditions, the
people didn't already attribute them to
the gospel.
>> If they're attributing to the go, that's
what I'm saying. They're attributing
them to the gospel. He doesn't tr he
doesn't know if it's in the gospel or
not. And so, uh, this one of these
things where they he thinks that they're
lying about Jesus.
>> How do you how do you how do you know
that? How do you know that he didn't
already know that they were in the
gospel?
>> Because he didn't know the scriptures.
He didn't know them. He couldn't read
them.
>> Okay? But look, when something is a oral
tradition, right? So let's say I tell
you, okay, it says this in the Quran
al-Nis, you know, 34, right? And then
you're listening to me and I tell you
what it says, right?
>> And then you say, "Okay, that's what it
says in the Quran. Let me write that
into the gospel." Okay?
>> So you see, you see, you see, it could
have been possible. It was most likely
possible actually that Muhammad already
knew that what they said about Jesus was
about Jesus inside of the gospel.
>> How?
>> Because he copied it and then he
attributed a lot to it.
>> But how how would he know that it's in
the scriptures if he can't possibly read
it? Like it's physically impossible for
him to read the scriptures. How would he
know that? What what's in the scriptures
and what isn't?
>> Because people told him about it.
>> Exactly. So people tell him stuff. So
it's like, so he's so he's taking what
he discerns himself, what he's deciding
to trust and like, oh no, that that
there's no way that that's about Jesus.
Like Jesus wouldn't say that. He's a
mere prophet. He served Allah, but this
is this is right for Allah. And then
attributes the characters of Jesus that
he said, the qualities of Jesus to
Allah.
>> I'm I'm not going to lie. I don't think
I don't think we're going to um cuz I
feel like we're both kind of doing a
little bit of reaching here. You know
what I'm saying? Cuz like really how do
you know
>> how do you know when they told him this
story they didn't already attribute it
to the gospel when he heard the story?
>> You don't you're missing the point. I'll
say it again, bro.
>> Okay.
>> If they attribute it to the gospel,
>> it doesn't matter. He does not know what
is in the gospel.
So they can say, "Hey, yeah, this is
what Jesus said in the gospel." He
doesn't know if Jesus actually said that
in the gospel. Matter of fact, if it
sounds too outlandish where it deifies
Jesus, he doesn't believe that. So, he's
going to reject that the gospel actually
said that, but apply those qualities to
Jesus, I mean to Allah.
He doesn't believe that they belong to
Jesus.
He thinks that they're lying about what
the gospel is saying about Jesus
and then confirms the gospel is true,
>> but he can't read. Why would he not just
be like, "Okay, you guys say that it
says that in the gospel. I trust you."
Why now would he try to flip a different
story onto that and be like, "Okay, it
actually doesn't say that in the gospel,
but I'm going to confirm the gospel even
though they told me that it deifies
Jesus."
>> He wants them to he wants them to
believe it. He doesn't believe he look
all throughout the Quran, you'll see the
Quran say they distort the book with
their tongues. They misinterpret the
scripture. They lie on the scripture.
They recite it wrongfully. Right?
>> But it also talk about it talks about
No, no, it doesn't. It never talks about
how this scripture is corrupted. And
I'll challenge you to to show me that
later. But I want you to understand this
point that throughout the Quran chapter
3 verse 78, chapter 4 verse uh 46 uh
chapter 2 verse 75, it talks about oral
distortion. After hearing the word, they
distort it. After uh uh they they hear
the word and understand it, they corrupt
it with their tongues. Uh chapter 5:13,
they uh misuse words from the right
places, meaning taking them out of
context. It always accuses the people of
verbally distorting the scriptures. So
they're always lying or misinterpreting
or misunderstanding the scriptures.
That's what the Quran always says.
That's that's Muhammad's belief.
>> Right. Right. I'm sorry, but like how do
you know exactly that those verses that
say, "Woe to those who twist the
scripture with their tongues isn't also
referring to written scripture."
I want you to say that one more time.
>> So, so the verse you're referring to,
right? I'm assuming.
>> No, no, just, just say it again. What
you just said, say it one more time. Ask
me the same exact question, word for
word.
>> So, the verse is asking about oral
transmission of the scripture, right?
It's your claim. But how do you know
that the verse
>> say what you just asked?
>> You know, I'm sorry, but I got to see
the exact verse that I'm quoting before
I
>> You just said when it says, "Woe to
those who distort the book with their
tongues." How do I know that? That's not
also textual corruption.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I'm not I'm not that talented, but
unless you got some people that can
write with their tongues.
>> No, I mean, even in even in like even
like I just said,
>> you got some freaks out there, man.
>> Yeah. But it does it does like it does
talk about woe to those who write the
scriptures with their own hands than say
this is from Allah.
>> Very good. Now there is a verse. It
says, "Woe to those who write the book
with their own hands, claiming it's from
Allah, seeking a small price or selling
it and seeking a small price." Right?
That's chapter 2 verse 79.
>> That still doesn't talk about the
textual corruption of the actual books.
For example, if I write a book,
One second, bro. Just hold that thought.
Okay? Don't don't take advantage of this
and like try to yap to the to the chat.
Just hold on a second. All right.
>> Oh,
yeah. Just just one one second. One
second. Get up.
>> Yo yo yo. Everybody stand up, bro.
Everybody stand up. Everybody stand up.
All
right. Got it.
Got it. Got it. Got it.
All right. I got my book. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I wrote this book with my own
hands. I literally have I made up I got
some stuff here and I even got some
verses in here. Okay. This book it says
that Avery is in the Quran. Uh, this is
divinely inspired. Avery is the last
prophet after Muhammad. My name is
Avery, by the way. Uh, bring something
like this if it ain't from God. Those
that's word for word what it says. Bring
something like this if it ain't from
God.
That's powerful speech right there.
Poetic.
This is the final revelation.
It also says Jesus is the son of God.
Uh, oh, this this verse is really good.
This book is a miracle. And then another
verse says, "This revelation came
through an angel." Okay. Now, I wrote
this with my own hands, and I'm claiming
that it came from God.
>> Yeah.
>> Does this mean that the Quran has been
corrupted?
>> Uh, no.
>> Why not? I wrote a book with my own
hands.
>> Read that book.
>> Huh?
>> Nobody's going to read that book.
>> Well, well, what if people do? What if I
What if I get thousands of people to
read it? What if I sell it to thousands
and people pick it up and they start
reading it? Would that mean that the
Quran is corrupted now?
>> I mean, if the original Quran literally
isn't here anymore and then that's the
only
>> No, no. The original Quran is here. The
Quran is here or whatever you call the
Quran is here after Umam burned them.
Um, and I wrote this with my own hands
and I claim it's from God. Does that
mean that the Quran is corrupted?
>> If that's more popular than the real
Quran, I would say yes. The Quran did
get corrupted.
So if this book becomes more popular
than the Quran, it gets in the hands of
more people around the world
>> in the Quran. You would say that in the
world,
>> you would say that the Qurans that the
that the Muslims have in their house, in
their houses and in their in their uh
cars and in their mazjids and mosques
and learning centers, those Qurans are
now corrupted because my book is now the
most popular book out of the two.
I don't even I don't even think that's
the claim that the Quran is making
though to be fair cuz the literally
Yeah. The Quran is literally talk about
people distorting scripture. It
>> doesn't say distort. It doesn't say
distort. It says right.
>> Yeah. Write their own scripture and
claim it from God.
>> Exactly. They're writing their own
scripture and claiming that it's from
God with their own hands. They're
writing fake books,
>> passing it off as if it's from God.
>> But you got to understand the conflation
that you're doing here because what's
the conflation?
>> Yeah. If Okay, so for example, if I
write down a scripture right now, okay,
I say this is the gospel. This is the
gospel of of
>> right here. No, this right here. No,
we're going to continue. Let's continue
to use the Let's continue to use this
and the Quran as the example. Don't
switch the examples. This I'm writing.
We got the Quran. Everybody got Qurans
in the household? I got I got all I got
three different three different Qurans
right here, you know. I got I got my
Qurans. Um
so we I got Qurans. Okay.
>> I wrote a book with my own hands. I
claimed it's from God. It got more
popular than the Quran.
>> Right.
>> Are the Qurans corrupted now?
Now, if that's what people claim to be
the Quran, then yes, I will say that the
Quran is now corrupted because we lost
the message. All we have is the all we
have is the Quran of God logic.
>> That's tough. Matter of fact,
>> that's so tough that that belongs to go
into the official red book.
>> What's the name? So but but the but the
point is the point is right the verse is
talking about those who write the
scripture with their own hands and then
say it's from Allah right
>> yeah like I just did
>> yeah so it's a so now you have to go
into a public area tell everybody okay
so imagine how small like Medina is as
area right so you come in to a rural
area right not a lot of people living
there you say this is the Quran this is
the Torah okay whatever and now Everyone
is believing you because you're the
rabbi. Okay? You're you're the one in
charge. Okay? He has the Torah. So now
you have essentially corrupted the book
because you're the people's authority.
You're who everybody goes to to listen
to and say, "Okay, I need to take the
Torah from him." You understand what I'm
saying? So yes, if you were to do
something like that, I would say
especially in a small like culture like
that, that is corruption.
>> Okay?
If your book becomes more popular than
the Quran,
>> then yes,
>> the Quran
Quran
is corrupted.
So according to you
it's not uh
it's not um textual
manuscripts and oral tradition that
preserves a book its popularity.
>> Yeah I would to an extent to an extent.
So if every
if if and and because I can't believe
this
ju just to say it again if my book
became the popular book among Muslims
and they started and they started saying
this is the Quran that means that the
Quran that I have right now in my hand
is now corrupted because it's not the
it's not popular anymore.
>> No that's still the Quran. I'm sorry.
I'm still I'm That is still the Quran.
The book that you have, if everybody's
reading that book and saying, "Okay,
this is the Quran." Then you have
corrupted the Quran.
>> How did I corrupt the Quran if I still
have the Quran?
>> Because that other book is now the Quran
according to you.
>> Is it truly the Quran though or?
>> No, it's not truly the Quran.
>> So then how did I corrupt the Quran if I
still have the Quran? Because you're
claiming that the book in your right
hand is the Quran and that's a corrupt
book.
>> This is a corrupt book.
>> No, in your left hand. Sorry. The
camera's flip. Yeah. If you're claiming
that that book in your left hand is the
Quran and everybody's reading that as
the Quran, that is corruption now
>> cuz you've corrupted not only the book,
you've corrupted the minds of everybody
to believe that that is the Quran.
>> So this means that the actual Quran is
textually corrupted.
>> No, no, no. You're saying the book in
your left hand is the Quran. That's the
problem.
>> Okay. Does this mean that the actual
Quran is corrupted now since I say the
one in my left hand is is is the real
Quran?
>> No, the book in your right hand is not
corrupted. The book in your left hand is
corrupted and everybody's reading the
book on your left hand. So that's the
point.
>> I got you. So maybe uh let's let's try
to redo this. I did not pay him, guys.
Um,
so really your point is
the Quran is not actually corrupted, but
the Muslims have been corrupted by this
lie, by this false book,
>> by this by this new Quran that you have,
which is also corrupted.
>> So it's so the actual Quran is not
corrupted, but the Muslim people have
been corrupted since they latched onto a
false book, right? Yes. And the book
because yes, the book is also corrupted.
And you're attributing that book with
being the Quran.
>> I'm giving them a cor I'm giving them a
false fabricated corrupted book.
>> Yes.
>> As the truth. The Muslims accept it as
the truth. And therefore, the Muslims
are corrupted themselves. But the
original Quran is not corrupted.
>> Yes. Because it's the word of God. The
word of God doesn't get corrupted.
>> Boom. Boom. Boom. Is the Torah the word
of God?
The Torah that was given to Moses. Yes.
>> Is the gospel the word of God?
>> The the the good news that was given to
Jesus. Yes.
>> So the Torah and Gospel are the words of
God and therefore they cannot be
corrupted. Right.
>> Listen. And the exact same way.
>> Now tell me. Listen. Answer answer.
>> Because they're the word of God. They
cannot be corrupted. Right.
>> Ex just like you just gave us that leg
posted book. Ah, I need an answer.
>> I'm I'm trying to give you an answer.
>> Okay. So, the the way to answer is to
answer me directly. It's either a it's a
it's a right or a wrong.
>> So, because the Torah is the word of God
and the cor and the gospel is the word
of God. That means they cannot be
corrupted. Right? Yes or no? the message
of Moses directly from him and no
>> it's listen because if I say yes right
because I do believe yes that the that
Moses's message the Torah that he
revealed to his people can be corrupted
>> and then the book and then the other
book that we have now the Torah
>> let me do this let me let me do it this
other way because it seems like the only
way that you can get things if if I use
the Quran as an example because there's
some type of mental block with you
people like you guys have a mental block
like If it's if we usually, oh yeah,
yeah, this this it makes sense when it
comes to the Quran. When it's outside
the Quran and it refers to other books,
oh yeah, no, you know, no, it doesn't.
Oh, yeah, that's correct. So, let's do
it this way.
>> The Quran is the word of God, correct?
>> Yes.
>> So, because the Quran is the word of
God, it cannot be corrupted, right?
>> No.
>> Oh, so it can be corrupted.
>> What?
>> It can be corrupted. Like I just said,
you can attribute a book as being from
Allah.
>> Can you corrupt the actual Quran, dude?
>> No. No. Not the direct message from God.
You can't.
>> Okay. So, the the the Torah, the Gospel,
the direct messages of God, can they be
corrupted? Yes or no?
>> No. And I'm going to tell you why.
Because God doesn't change his mind.
>> You're right.
>> God's message stays the same.
>> You're absolutely You don't You don't
got to tell me, brother. You ain't got
to tell me twice. Right.
>> So with that being said, with that being
said, you cannot double talk and then
say after what you just said, you cannot
then say that the Torah and Gospel are
corrupted.
>> Okay?
>> Because you just said that that's
impossible.
>> The claim I'm making here is a book can
be corrupted. Okay? A book can be
corrupted, but the word of God, his law,
will always stay the same. You
understand what I'm trying to say?
>> Can this book be corrupted?
Yes, someone can easily go into that
book, write something down, and say,
"Okay, this is the Quran."
>> So, the Quran, go get a pen, exile a
certain ex out a certain letters inside
of the Quran, and then attribute
something else to it.
>> I got you. So, the Quran the Quran can't
be corrupted.
>> Not the Quran from Allah, not his word.
You're you're going to you're going to
try what I said.
>> No, no, I got you. So, this is not
Allah's word. It's just a book. Is that
right?
>> I'm not too far off wrong from saying
that.
So, is that right? The Qurans that you
are your parents Muslim?
>> No.
>> Okay.
Um, you go to the imams and shakes at
your at your mosque?
>> Uh, yeah.
>> Do you guys use Qurans in your mosques?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. The Quran that I have, the Qurans,
cuz these are all different ones. the
Qurans that your shakes and imams use
when they give you lessons in the mosque
and you guys possibly read from them. I
don't know how that goes or whatever.
And the Qurans in all of the Muslim
households, all the masids in the world,
those are not really Quran. Those are
not the word of God,
right? They're just books.
>> They're kab. Yeah, they're kab.
>> They're just books. So, and I won't do
this, but So, if I ripped a page out of
this book
and spat on it or whatever, would you be
offended?
>> Yeah, I'll be offended.
>> Why would you be offended? It's just a
book.
>> Because that's not how we're supposed to
discard the Quran.
>> This ain't This ain't the Quran, though.
You just said it's not the Quran.
>> No, listen. Listen.
>> You just said it's not the Quran.
There's no Look, there's no mistakes in
that book. Everything inside of that
book is exactly as
>> That's fine. I have a math book where
there's no mistakes in it either. Who
cares? You told me this ain't the Quran.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, that's not the point that I'm
trying to make. That book right as you
have it. Do the oral transmission from
the time of Muhammad is how it was that
time. Okay.
>> I disagree with that, but let me go I'll
let you have this for now. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Because that's an argument for
another day. So if the oral transmission
and the way it is written down stays the
same up until now that is exactly how
the Quran was revealed the book that's
exactly how the book and the law from
God was revealed.
>> So what it's just the book though at the
end of the day right it's not it's not
it's not it's not God's actual word it's
not Allah's word
>> you can make that argument for any uh
religious text I mean it's just pen and
paper at the end of the day.
>> Sure. So so so do are you so this right
here in and of itself is not the word of
God. It's not the actual Quran as you
said earlier, right?
>> The information and the message inside
of it is the Quran.
>> How long you been Muslim?
>> Uh about three years.
>> And then when did you become full
Muslim?
>> Uh about three years ago.
>> Oh, so the as soon as you said your
shahada, it was immediate full Muslim.
Of course.
>> Nice.
>> You want to hear something? I'm going to
share something with you, bro.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
I'm going to give you some advice.
And this is probably the second best
advice that I can give you other than
come to Christ, man, and leave Islam
because you don't have to do this. But
here's the second best advice that I can
give you. Okay. Here. Never go full
Muslim. Don't do it. Never go full
Muslim. Don't lose it. Once full Muslim,
when your brain shut off, then you say
something stupid and you try to play it
off. Never go full Muslim. Ding. Never
go full Muslim.
Go full Muslim ding. Never go full
Muslim.
Full Muslim. Oh no. Oh no. Full Muslim.
Full Muslim. Just don't. Full Muslim
explode.
Oh my god, bro.
>> Yo,
>> don't do it, man. Don't go full Muslim.
You never do it.
>> All right. Uh, I'm Cuz I know you're
probably going to kick me, so I'm going
to leave you with one last message. Uh,
>> I'm not going to kick you.
>> Okay.
>> You cool people, man. You want to keep
talking?
>> Yeah. I'm just like cuz you know
obviously you know the Quran actually
tells us on on the on the opposite end
because obviously I don't know if you've
been presented to the uh proofs towards
Islam being true but the Quran tells us
on the opposite end it asks you to
actually prevent to uh propose your
proofs for Christianity being true. So
I'm wondering what what exactly is that?
What is your proof?
>> Where does the Quran where does the
Quran tell me to do that? You don't
know. You don't know the You don't know
the ayah as the Jews and Christians to
profess their proofs?
>> No. No. What What verse is that?
>> All right. Let me go to my notes right
quick.
>> Okay. While While you get that, I'm
going to read some super chats. Okay.
You just just talk when you're ready.
All right.
Okay. We got a full Muslim on our hands,
y'all. And I'm And I'm out here busting
out a word and I hearing them out. But
it's all good, man. It's all good, bro.
Um, let's see here.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, you found it. Dang, I didn't even
get to my super chat. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. Bakuh
versus 111.
>> And they say, "None will enter paradise
except those who are Jews and
Christians." That is your thinking.
Produce your proof if you be truthful.
>> About what? About entering paradise. Is
that right?
>> No. No. About about your religion. If if
you claim that only people only Jews or
Christians will enter paradise, if that
is your wishful thinking, produce your
proof if you should be truthful.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. I like that. Nice. So,
so you're asking me what is my proof to
be
uh or that Christianity is true.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure. Um,
that's a that's a good Wow, you put me
on the spot there, man.
Um,
okay. You ready for this?
>> Yeah.
>> You sure?
>> I'm listening.
>> All right. When I show you this,
when I show you this, man, ain't no
turning back.
Ain't no turn it back. All right.
>> All right.
All right. Uh do me a favor, man. Go
ahead and go to chapter uh go to chapter
61, man, in the Quran.
>> Wait, I mean, I'll do it, but I mean the
question was for your proofs as being a
Christian. I don't know.
>> Yeah, you asked me for the proof that
Christianity is true, right?
>> Yeah. So chapter 61 of the Quran uh
which verse
>> 14.
>> Oh you who have believed be supporters
of Allah as Jesus the son of Mary said
to the disciples who are my supporters
for Allah. The disciples said we are
supporters of Allah. And a faction of
the children of Israel believed but a
faction disbelieved. So we supported
those who believed against their enemy
and they became dominant.
Okay.
So it says that the disciples of Jesus
became helpers of Allah. Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> What does that mean to be a helper of
Allah in this context?
>> Uh I would assume a monotheist, you
know, pious in their faith.
>> Yeah. But when Jesus is saying
who will be my helpers in the of Allah?
Who will be my helpers of Allah? So
they're doing something Jesus is doing.
Jesus is doing something and then Jesus
is asking him them to help him do that
for Allah. Help me help Allah. Right.
Disciples say we'll do it. We'll we'll
step up and we'll we'll be helpers of
Allah.
>> Yeah.
>> What what does it mean? What does that
mean? What are they what are they doing
to be helpers of Allah?
>> Um
so like I just said, I assume they're
being pious worshippers of God going
through that.
>> Well, they're already that they they are
already monotheist. They are already
pious worshippers of God. They're
already following Jesus.
But he didn't ask for something else. He
asked them to help Allah.
>> I mean uh the the Arabic in here says
Allah which is like a spiritual uh like
practical you know meaning.
>> It means to support Allah and to help
him.
Obviously this doesn't mean that oh
Allah's like not all powerful. He needs
our help. But it's a particular action
that's being done. What are they doing
that helps Allah?
And the same thing that Jesus is doing.
Cuz remember, they're they're already
monotheists. They're already believers.
So, it's not that.
>> I'm curious as to how more you could
help God by other than just worshiping
him
>> by by spreading his message.
Yeah. Jihad, I guess.
>> By preaching, spreading spreading the
message,
>> right? So,
>> so they're going around. They said,
"We'll do it. We'll be helpers of
Allah." And then watch what is right.
Right after it says that they said,
"We'll do it. We'll be helpers of
Allah." What what what happens? Keep
reading. All right. After that,
>> all right, hold on.
You lost the verse.
>> Yeah, I closed out the tab.
>> Oh, man. Man, keep that tab open, man.
>> Indeed, Allah loves those who fight in
his cause and rose.
>> No, no. Same same verse. Same verse cuz
it's chapter 61:14.
That's the last chapter of the I mean
the last verse of the chapter.
>> Okay. So, oh you who have believed be
supporters of Allah and affection and
disbelief. Indeed, Allah loves those who
fight in his cause and rose as if they
were single structured.
>> What is that? That's not the verse.
>> Are you sure?
>> Chapter 61:14.
Oh believers, be ye helpers of Allah.
Just as Jesus asked the disciples, said
to the disciples, who will be my helpers
of Allah? That's what the verse says.
You just read it, bro.
>> Chapter 16. Chapter 61 verse14.
Okay.
All right. All right. All right. All
right. I'm back on the page.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> Oh believers, oh believers, stand up for
Allah. As Jesus, son of Mary, asked the
disciples, "Who will stand up? Who will
stand up with me for Allah?" The
disciples replied, "We will stand up for
Allah." Then a group of Then a group
from the children of Israel believed
while another disbelieved that we
supported the believers. Then we
supported the believers against their
enemies. Then they prevailed.
>> So
they they announced and said we'll stand
up for for Allah with you. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So then that then it goes on to say
okay. So then so some of the people of
Israel believed and some disbelieved and
we supported the believers against their
enemies and they prevailed. Really in
the Arabic it says they became dominant.
Okay. Uh so the believers of Jesus
were spreading the message. They were
help spreading the message of Jesus.
help spreading the message of Allah
and they prevailed against their enemies
that tried to stop them from doing so
however it was maybe trying to persecute
them conver uh corrupt their message
whatever and so the message of Jesus
through the believers Allah supported
them helped them spread the message
right against their enemies
right
>> um yeah
>> okay and in doing so they became
victorious They beca they prevailed
against them. They became dominant.
Their message prevailed against their
enemies against the disbelievers. Right?
>> Okay. So
this demonstrates that the enemies of
Jesus could not have come and corrupted
the message of Jesus or you know just
like get rid of it all together just you
know take over whatever. Allah helped
them, the believers prevail against the
enemies and they became dominant. The
Quran says now
go to chapter 3:55. This is this is
linked directly. It tells you how long
they prevailed, how long they were
dominant. Chapter 3,
>> Imran,
sorry.
>> Chapter number three. We're gonna get
this karat.
Thank you, Danny.
>> All right.
>> Verse 55.
>> Watch how true Christianity is, man. I'm
bringing my dil. I'm bringing my proof.
>> Why is the app's not working? Hold on.
Let me get Let me get the real book. The
app's not working.
>> Okay. All
right. While he's getting that, I'm
gonna read some super chats.
Uh, let's see.
What's funny, a massive portion of Allah
99 names are the names of the
pre-Islamic pagan gods, including Al
Rahman. Like the guest just said, it's
based off of constellations in the sky
they worshiped. Super chat from Phil.
I'm just reading super chats, bro. I'm
just reading super chats, man.
Alex says, "I really, really, really
like this topic. Allah Allah unbbiten
himself.
Give Jesus the swag back, little itty
bitty G. You ain't living like that or
alive at all, man."
>> But which verse? Which verse was it?
>> 55.
CSJ says, "If they say that the Bible
was not from Jesus, that makes the Quran
even worse because it's then copying
from mere uninspired men." Is that the
case?
>> Ron says, "Thank you for your work,
brother. So many Muslims left to come to
the gospel." Amen.
>> All right, I found the verse.
>> All right. So remember when Allah said,
"Oh Jesus, I will take you and raise you
up to myself. I will deliver you from
those who disbelieve and elevate your
followers above the disbelievers until
the day of judgment.
>> Then to me, you will all return and
settle all your disputes."
>> So Allah says that he is going to
elevate the believers
above the disbelievers. So again, right
right in line with 61:14, he supported
the believers of Jesus against the
disbelievers and they prevailed against
them. And how long will they remain
uppermost? How long will they remain
dominant over the disbelievers? Until
when?
>> The day of judgment.
>> Until the day of judgment. So there's no
point in time that from the time of
Jesus until this day all the way until
judgment day, there's no point in time
where the disbelievers can be elevated
or prevailing or dominant over the
actual believers and followers of Jesus.
That must mean that means that whatever
the dominant message of the followers of
Jesus is what has been the prevailing
message among the followers of Jesus
from then all the way until now the
dominant message that's the true message
that Allah helped spread and that he
elevated.
So let me ask you this among those who
claim to be followers of Jesus what is
the dominant message in regards to
Jesus? Like let's say for example just
to keep it simple about his crucifixion.
What's the dominant message about his
crucifixion?
>> The dominant message of Jesus
crucifixion
>> is it that is it that he wasn't
crucified or that he was crucified and
rose again.
>> Yeah. So secular scholars believe he was
crucified and not rose again but Yeah.
Yeah. That I would say so according to a
secular viewpoint the uh dominant
position is that he was crucified. Yes.
>> Yeah. And now according to the followers
of Jesus, the ones who claim to be
followers of Jesus, right? Like the
Christians,
what what's the dominant message?
>> Aha. But problem cuz Muslims also claim
to be followers of Jesus.
>> You're right. And what is the dominant
message though? What is the most
prominent dominant message that has
prevailed from then all the way until
now about the crucifixion of Jesus? Is
it the Muslims message that Jesus wasn't
crucified, but that he was saved? Or is
it that Jesus was crucified and rose
again?
>> That he was crucified and rose again.
That was the most popular message. Yeah.
>> Yep. So that must mean that that's the
message that Allah helped spread and
elevate. Meaning that's the true message
that my Christianity is true even
according to your Quran.
>> But how do you know that's the message
he's talking about?
>> Because that's the message that
dominated. And he said that he made the
believers of Jesus dominant prevailing
over the disbelievers and they will
remain elevated above them until the day
of resurrection. So whatever
>> you know by message he's not just
referring to like common themes like
monotheism and uh you know prophethood
of Moses.
>> It's whatever they was preaching.
>> It's whatever they was preaching. It
says that they will be helpers of Allah.
So they're going and they're spreading
the message of Allah. they're preaching.
And so whatever the the dominant message
was that they were preaching, that's
what that's the message that Allah
helped. Unless you want to say that the
disbelievers actually prevailed against
the actual believers and infiltrated the
message by putting in the crucifixion of
Jesus and his resurrection and therefore
Allah failed to keep his promise and
then Islam is false.
>> Right. So I mean I mean I like that
argument. It's not a horrible argument.
It's actually a pretty good argument.
This is like somebody for like a a taps
expert to like go over. But like I mean
to be fair that wasn't my question. My
question was like cuz imagine the Quran
is according to you. You don't even
believe in it. So my question was what
is your proof
excluding religious scripture like the
Quran?
>> No. Why would I do that?
>> You're a Muslim.
>> So I'm going to use proof and evidences
that are relevant to you. I'm not just
going to give you anything. I'm going
use stuff that is relevant to you. So
I'm showing I'm showing you that from
your own Quran, from your own sources,
my religion is the truth.
>> I mean, but like the biggest enemy of
Christianity even isn't even Muslim.
It's more
>> Yes, it is. It's Islam and secularism.
It's both
>> secularism is I mean most
>> I'll say Islam first.
>> No, no, because most Christians who
leave Christianity become secular
atheists.
>> No.
>> Uh a a big portion might become Muslim.
Yes. But All of that is irrelevant to
what we're saying right now, what we're
talking about.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But I mean, my my case is
just like, what if I was a Christian who
left to be secular?
>> All right. Leave Islam. Leave Islam and
aspire to be a Christian and I'll give
you the proofs on why the Bible is true
aside from the Quran. But as long as you
remain as long as you proclaim ill, I'm
going to show you from your Quran that
my religion
>> I mean, don't you don't you also uh
proclaim?
>> No. You don't you don't believe that
there is one God and
>> I don't believe it's Allah, bro.
>> I don't believe I don't believe it's
Allah.
>> Allah just means the God.
>> Whatever you say, bro.
>> Stay focused. Stay focused on what we're
saying on what we're talking about.
>> Okay?
>> So, as long as you're as long as you're
a Muslim and prof and professing Islam
and professing Muhammad as your prophet,
I will continue to use your Quran to
demonstrate to you how my religion is
the truth.
There's no way around it. leave Islam
and then I'll show you why the Bible
stands alone without the Quran's help.
>> So, so your argument basically is uh cuz
you know you're you're kind of sticking
me to this like
>> basically I'm holding you to the Quran
unfortunately. Huh.
>> No, no, that's not what I'm saying. I'm
talking about this argument in
particular. I was I was like my question
initially was you know what is just
proof for Christianity in general?
>> Yeah. You asked me what was the proof
that Christianity was true. I gave you
my dil. I gave you my proof. The Quran
says it. The Quran says it's true.
What what what better proof is that for
you as a Muslim? Would you rather would
you rather me use secular people or
would you rather me use Allah?
>> But this isn't even this isn't even the
argument that the Quran
>> you're not even answering my question.
Would you rather me point to secular
evidences and what they say or would you
rather me point to what Allah says?
Which one is
>> I want sec? I want I want I want
biblical evidence of why Christianity
was true.
>> So would you rather me use what Allah
says or what other than Allah says?
Which one is more reliable
>> for for Islam? Then I would ask
>> for you. You're a Muslim,
>> right? So you So your claim is would I
rather you use evidence from the Bible
to prove Islam or would I rather you use
evidence from the
>> I'll say it again.
I'll say it again. You heard what I
said.
So don't play dumb with me.
What is more reliable,
Allah's words or other than Allah's
words?
>> Allah's words. Yeah.
>> Okay. So with me dealing with you whose
utmost authority is the words of Allah
that you deem as in the Quran,
why in Allah's gehenna would I go to
anything else? I'm going to use what you
deem as authoritative and resourceful.
I'm going to use that to demonstrate to
you that my religion is true, which I
just did. Unless you can show me
otherwise.
I mean the show you otherwise would just
be that the Quran doesn't even uh affirm
that the crucifixion happened and
>> so then the Quran is false then
>> no because the verse lit the verse like
there's a clearer verse literally saying
that Jesus wasn't crucified and that he
was raised to heaven.
>> Well they didn't crucify him nor did
they nor did they kill him but it was
made to appear. So that's what the Quran
says. Let let me take your
interpretation and say that that is what
that's contradicting or that's uh saying
the cor the crucifixion didn't happen.
Okay. Well, that would just mean that
the Quran is false for propagating and
pushing a message and religion that
teaches that Jesus was crucified and
resurrected. That's the dominant
message.
So, it's either
it's well either way you go Islam is
false because if since the dominant
message is that Jesus died by
crucifixion and rose again on the third
day since that's the dominant message
that has to be the message that Allah
helped spread which then contradicts the
Quran and so therefore the Quran is
false for going against the true message
of Allah that he spread or
this that the death and resurrection
isn't the true message of the believers
that Allah helped and supported and it's
the disbelievers and their message that
dominated and prevailed against the
believers which contradicts what the
Quran says and therefore Allah failed to
keep his promise and Islam is lost.
>> I mean Muslims don't damn I really don't
even I really don't even know how to
tackle this. I don't even I'll have to
you know actually research this for
myself you know I really I really don't
even know the answer for the question.
It's a It's a good one, though, huh? I
appreciate your humility, brother.
That's good. But it's a It's a good It's
a good It's It's solid, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, that's my proof for you. My
proof for you is that that is this right
here. And
uh you know,
>> so uh your proof is basically that the
Quran says Christianity is true. That's
your proof.
>> That's my proof for you. So then you
take So then you take uh Islam as being
authorative.
>> Uh I for you. You asked me to show you
the proof. So for you. Yes.
>> Right.
>> I I believe in the original Quran before
it before it got corrupted.
>> Damn. What is this like? What is this
verse? What is it? What is this saying?
Like this
>> it's saying exactly what it's saying,
dude. It's not saying other it's not
saying anything else other than what
you're reading. And this is the problem,
bro. Hear, hear me when I'm saying this,
dude.
>> But but like who are the followers of
Jesus? This verse is referring to
>> exactly. It's talking about his
disciples. His disciples and those who
will follow them. Because remember, it's
not just talking about Jesus this time.
It's talking about until the day of
resurrection. So even the followers of
Jesus that will come after the disciples
all from for generations, the followers
of Jesus will remain dominant until the
day of resurrection.
>> Right? But Muslims believe that we are
the followers of Jesus.
>> Exactly.
That's that's the problem. You believe
you're followers of Jesus, but yet
you're contradicting the dominant
message of the followers of Jesus. So,
you're not really followers of Jesus.
You're on the wrong side. You're on the
disbelieving side.
But then the Quran affirms what you're
saying that he wasn't crucified. He's
not the son of God. The Quran affirms
what you're saying. So therefore, the
Quran is going against the true message,
the dominant message that Allah helped
spread. And so the Quran's false. It
fails. It's a dilemma. Either way you
go, Islam is false. If the if the
dominant message is the is is what Allah
helped, that means that Islam is false
because it goes against the dominant
message. Yes. But my but my dominant
message like is like cuz the message cuz
the message that you're saying that
Jesus was crucified this was even an
opinion held by even the Romans and the
pagans at that time. So how could we
like like the crucifixion as Muslims? I
mean as anyone would know the
crucifixion is not the main point of
Christianity.
>> Yes.
>> It is the crucifixion and the
resurrection is the main point of
Christianity. Literally, this is what it
says.
>> But but Unitarians also believe in a
crucifixion and a resurrection.
>> Absolutely. Now, these aren't these
aren't real Christians, but yes,
absolutely. But who cares about them?
But the point is is that look, according
to according to the Christians, the
followers of Jesus, the Christian faith
is in vain if Jesus did not rise from
the dead. That's 1 Corinthians chapter
15. If Jesus did not rise from the dead,
then our faith is in vain. That's what
the Bible says.
>> The resurrection of Christ is our main
is the is the main uh of Christianity.
It's the proof.
>> So, so by message of yo cuz your message
of Christianity is uh the trinity and
the resurrection of Jesus. So, so
according to you,
>> right, that would be that would have to
be the main message that would have
prevailed over time.
>> Yes. According to Muslims,
according to Muslims, right, the
argument is that the message of
monotheism, right, that Jesus br was the
message that was going to prevail over
time. So, how could that
>> trinity is monotheism? So, it doesn't
>> I mean,
>> so are you are you saying are you saying
non-trinitarian monotheism?
>> Talking about talking about unity of
God, one God.
>> Okay. So, so non-trinitarian monotheism.
So I mean that's that's an argument for
another day. But
>> so so monotheism that does not depict
the trinity. You're saying that that's
what that's that was the message of
Jesus, right?
>> If that's how you interpret it, but I
don't think the trinity is monotheism at
all.
>> Whatever. That's that's cool. But so
that's what you're saying.
Non-rinitarianism,
>> right? According to the Quran, the
message of Jesus was to was unity of
God. And that message did prevail.
>> Okay. So let's let's work this out.
Let's plug this into what the Quran is
saying. So let's say let's go with you.
Jesus's message was talhed and the
followers of Jesus right after his
disciples and those after continue to
preach talhed.
>> Okay.
Now let me ask you amongst the followers
of Jesus what is the dominant message?
Is it or is it trinity?
today. Um I mean even for today there's
low-key some debates because you know
>> of course there's debate but what's the
dominant view in Christianity
there's debates about tahed and stuff
but you know
>> tahed is you know the thing what what is
the dominant what's the dominant belief
and message in Christianity when it
comes to the nature of God is it tahed
or is it Christian or trinity
>> I mean I can't give you a direct
statistic I honestly wouldn't know the
answer to that
I assume the answer you want is trinity.
But like the problem is like with me
saying that a lot of Christians believe
Jesus is not God and he's just the son
of God. That is
>> no no Christian believes that. You
talking about uh Aryan heretics is not
talking about Christianity, dude.
>> No, I'm like I'm just talking like from
my day-to-day life. But
>> I know from your day-to-day life you
talk to non-Christians who profess to be
Christians who don't who reject the
Trinity and the deity of Christ. Who
cares? I do not care about heretics. I
care about Christians.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I would say um from from
your viewpoint, I don't
>> No, not my not from my viewpoint.
Objectively, don't do that. Objectively,
what is the message of the followers of
Jesus when it comes to the nature of
God? Is it tawhed or is it Trinity?
Which one is dominant among the
followers of Jesus?
>> Yeah, but like I said, Muslims think
we're the followers of Jesus.
>> So, which one is dominant? Who cares?
Which one is is the dominant prevailing
message? Is it or is it Trinity?
>> Are you talking about numbers? Like
which who's more who's more prevalent,
Christians or Muslims?
>> Why you just looking at me?
>> All right, bro.
>> All right, man. I'm going give you
another chance
and and if you if you're going to
continue to play games with me after
this, then that's it. I'm going to let
you go. I'm ask you again. And be
honest, bro, cuz you were honest before
and which gave me hope, which is why
you've been here this long.
Don't play games, man. Don't disappoint
me.
Among those who are followers of Jesus,
who claim to be followers of Jesus,
which is the dominant message and view
in regards to God's nature? Is it
taleded or is it the Trinity?
>> You would probably say Trinity. So, uh,
but I do believe Islam is more prevalent
than Christianity. And I know you're
going to let me off into saying that,
but I think there's more Muslims than
Christians in the world. That's that's
just that's just, you know, statistics.
>> Okay. All right.
>> All right.
>> Thanks.
And there it goes.
In order to be a Muslim, you got to sink
your head under the sand and play as
dumb as you can to stay Muslim.
to stay Muslim you have the way that you
have to cope is in is I've never seen it
in any other cult
you see coping in Mormonism you see
coping in Jehovah's Witnesses
you in just in my experience
in my experience I have never seen
such level of stupidity willful
stupidity um copium just sipping
stepping on copium, coping so hard for
your religion,
uh willful dumbness and and and
ignoring real like just a detachment
from reality than Islam. I I haven't
seen anything like it. I really haven't.
Now, that's my experience. I'm not
saying that this is objectively the
case. I'm pretty sure some of my folks
out there who deal with Jehovah's
Witnesses or deal with Mormonism that
you guys might have something to say
about this.
Maybe we can all do a a stream where we
debate which religion is more detached
from reality. Which which religion have
you seen uh uh seep into the deepest
reaches of copehood and um willful
ignorance and willful tarted readation
of all time. Like
I haven't seen anything like this
personally,
but Islam is it's
Yeah.